-Welcome back, everybody.
We're here with Gayle King!
Costume change!
-First time ever.
-First-time costume change.
-It might become a thing now.
-Yeah.
-It's addicting once you do
a costume change.
Alright, let's get started.
This looks like a real thing
here right now.
-Yeah. So --
-This was -- This just went on.
-Yeah, so it's a warmer.
-It's a warmer.
-So, there's 104 items.
Price range from $18 to $900.
The most expensive
is an espresso.
But this, we thought,
was very cool because this is --
You could call this the Uber
or the iPhone of toasters.
-Okay.
-You can get six
different shades of brownness
depending on what you like.
-Okay.
-So it stays crunchy on the
outside, soft on the inside.
It also has a panini maker.
-Alright.
-Panini in the toaster.
-Oh, that's very exciting.
We pre-made our paninis
out of the interest of time.
-And, Seth, you can warm up
the cookies if you want to.
-That's very exciting.
-$510.
I know it's a little pricey,
guys.
But $210, 20%, off with
the code "OPRAH." O-P-R-A-H.
-If you can remember that.
Thanks for spelling it.
-We think this is cool.
This is cool. Revolution.
-Now, this is actually --
You are wearing this.
-Now, this is what
I wanted to change into.
Because this is a woman who
made this. Small business.
-Uh-huh.
-Isn't this cute?
Just backstage, somebody said,
"Gayle, that's very chic."
-You know,
when you're wearing it,
you don't have to hold it up
in front of you.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
Okay. Okay, Seth.
-Just saying, you know?
-Okay. This is a size medium.
I'm gonna give it to you.
-[ Seth speaking muffled ]
-No, I'm gonna give it to you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Size medium. Thank you.
I know, but you're right.
You're right. You're right.
You're right.
You just look like a medium.
-This is not the "Oprah" show.
We do not give things
to our guests!
[ Laughter ]
-That's just from me to you,
ma'am.
-Alright. That's wonderful.
-And she looked like
a size medium.
-It looks very comfortable.
-This is a Rivet Utility.
I think it's chic.
You can dress it up,
dress it down. $295.
-Mm-hmm.
-Oprah lives and breathes
in these, so we like this.
-I know this is a jigsaw.
-Now, this is puzzle.
Yeah, we love these.
-Okay. Okay.
-This happened, you know --
Actually during the pandemic,
can you imagine Oprah
and Stedman doing puzzles?
They did.
-They did do puzzles.
A lot of people I knew
did puzzles.
-Yeah, I saw her
on the Internet.
I called and said, "Did you guys
really do a puzzle,
or is that just a shtick?"
She goes, "No, we really did."
So we like this.
Jiggy Puzzle Kit.
Something good
for you and your kids.
-Alright. Great.
-Now, this, I think, is great.
So your kids will --
You've got three children.
-Uh-huh.
-They like to color.
They like to draw.
-See, this makes sense because
I'm not already wearing it.
-Yeah, so, see --
I know. I know, I know.
That was kind of a dweeb move.
I know, I know, I know.
I know. I get it.
-So wait. What is --
Tell me about it.
-Okay, so they draw it,
and then you send it
into this apron company,
and they put it on an apron.
-Ah, so this is
a child's drawing.
-So, it comes with all of these.
-Oh, gotcha.
-So, I think any --
Anytime you can display
your children's artwork,
I think that's a good thing.
This is Cece DuPraz.
Draw your own aprons.
-Draw your own apron. Beautiful.
-$78.
We like that, too.
-Now, can we take a bite of the
cookie that's been warmed here?
-I want a bite
of the grilled cheese.
-Yeah, have a bite
of the grilled cheese,
and then we'll share the cookie.
-Alright.
-Very warm. It worked.
-But don't you think
this is cool, though?
-I think it's very cool.
-No, you -- Ooh, it is actually
very warm, guys.
-Yeah.
-I don't know why I'm surprised
because I have
tried this before.
-That was a crazy thing
for you to say.
-I know. I know.
-"It turns out,
I haven't been lying to you."
-I have never lied to you!
Never lied to you!
-Well, lucky people,
you guys have --
I guess it's a --
Is it a sweepstakes?
12 lucky people have a chance
to win all...
-At OprahDaily.com.
-All 104 items on the list
on the 12 days
giveaway sweepstakes,
courtesy of Oprah Daily.
-That's right.
-Visit
OprahDaily.com/favoritethings
for more information.
You guys,
that's Gayle King, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
The full list
of Oprah's Favorite Things
is now live at OprahDaily.com
and will be featured
in the winter 2022 issue of
"O Quarterly" on newsstands.
We'll be right back
with Bobby Cannavale.